الاسباب مختلفه والخوف واحد عظمه بريطانيا
العظمى في خطر نموا اوسع في القوميه سواء
كانت اسكتلنديه متمثله في نزعه استقلاليه
الجديده قديمه او القوميه الانجليزيه التي
انعكست في بريك وبموت الملكه الثانيه
وفضائح الاسره الملكيه فظائرت هيبه ورمزيه
التاج لشعوب المملكه المختلفه هيبه تمثلت
عندما خرجت الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه عن خط
الحياد ودعت الاسكتلنديين للتفكير مليا في
المستقبل قبل استفتاء الاستقلال عام 2014
حتى دول الكومنويلث التي حافظت على
الرمزيه الدوليه للتاج البريطاني توزعت
بين من غادر مثل باربيدس ومن يدرس خيار
المغادره كاستراليا ونيوزيلندا
خروجه غلاسكو من عباءه لندن ان حدث له
عواقب امنيه ايضا فالحزب الوطني
الاسكتلندي اكد انه لن يسمح للغواصات
النوويه البريطانيه الاربع ان تبقى في
قاعده فاسلين